we are here today to remember a man of
God who lived by faith a man who
believed in things not seen a man who
believed there were better days ahead in
the distance a man of service who
persevered yeah knowing full well he
would not receive all those things he
was promised because he believed his
efforts would deliver a better life for
those who follow we do not know whether
the killer of Reverend pickney
and eight others knew all of this
history but he surely sensed the meaning
of his violent act for many by Dan white
that flag was a reminder of systemic
oppression
and racial subjugation we see that now
removing the flag from this States
capital would not be an act of political
correctness it would not be an insult to
the Valor of Confederate soldiers it
would simply be an acknowledgement that
the cause for which they fought the
cause of slavery was wrong for too long
we've been blind to the unique mayhem
that gun violence inflicts upon this
nation the vast majority of Americans
the majority of gun owners want to do
something about this we see that now
and I'm convinced that by acknowledging
the pain and loss of others even as we
respect the traditions ways of life that
make up this Beloved Country by making
the moral choice to change we express
God's grace